So, how did this happen? Pavlov always predicted meat powder in the dog's
mouth. The sight of Pavlov meant meat powder was coming. Pavlov wanted to test
this experimentally, so what he did was he provided a neutral stimulus, a tone
[SOUND]
, followed by meat powder, and he did this repeatedly. Tone
, meat powder, tone sss , meat powder. Then he wanted to see whether or not the
tone was able to produce salivation. Here he presents the tone alone.
[SOUND]
And the dog did salivate. The essence of classical conditioning is the pairing
process, where a formally neutral stimulus,
[SOUND]
becomes a conditioned stimulus. Predictive ability is the key.